guys let's uh take it back here now to
our bill of the month series that's of
course our partnership with Kaiser
health news and NPR this morning we are
looking at Medical Billing mistakes and
the case of two Grace Elliots it
involved a California woman who visited
a hospital in Florida nearly a decade
ago and then she found herself on the
hook for another patient's surgery bill
Grace Elliott was confused when she
received an eleven hundred dollar
surgery bill from a hospital in Venice
Florida thousands of miles from her
California home and so my first thought
was maybe it's a scam I called the
hospital and
we figured out that it wasn't my bill
it was someone else's bill
the actual surgery patient was 81 year
old Grace A Elliott but short Point
Health built 31 year old Grace E Elliott
whose name was still in the hospital
database from a 2013 visit eventually
the debt was sold to a collection agency
I wondered is this going to affect my
credit the debt collector told me we
can't speak to you about this account
you need to talk to the hospital and the
hospital told me
um well we fixed everything the debt
collector Medical Data Systems kept
building the younger Grace Elliott and
even sent her the older patients medical
records because of all the information
they sent me I was able to find this
other woman I wanted to let her know
about all of this so that she could know
that her and personal information was
out there after months of frustration
Grace E Elliott asked Kaiser health news
to investigate and soon received a
written apology from the hospital Shore
Point Health told CBS News quote the
hospital clearly made a mistake here the
error has been corrected and steps have
been taken to ensure it will not happen
again Medical Data Systems declined to
comment about the case but told Kaiser
health news it quote follows all state
and federal rules and regulations and
Grace E Elliott says the collection
letters have finally stopped we're
coming on a year later and that's it's
wasted a lot of my time this could have
been fixed so easily
Kaiser health news editor-in-chief Dr
Elizabeth Rosenthal joins us now Dr
Rosenthal I mean this woman did
everything right yet this still happened
is this common well we don't know how
common it is but yes it's very easy with
electronic medical records to insert
mistakes and then those mistakes are are
perpetuated kind of to Eternity yeah and
how can changes be made in order for
this not to happen again well what I
recommend is that everyone take a look
at that patient portal most of us are
like oh it's a headache to do that but
it's really important and if you see a
mistake there start early and get it
corrected do whatever it takes even if
it takes going into the medical records
office and sitting there with your arms
folded until they do so I've comb
through it and find the mistakes yeah
because in this case it was a mistake of
identity it might be a mistake of you're
allergic to a drug that you're not or
that you have a disease you don't I mean
there are many problems I'm surprised
that these uh medical organizations are
still sending uh or they're still
selling I'm not sure how it works
exactly to debt collectors who we've
done tons of stories about how
unscrupulous debt collectors are they
harass people they harass family members
of people why are they still doing this
well we did an investigation this year
called diagnosis debt and we called
hundreds of hospitals we estimated about
a quarter of them do sell debt to debt
collectors and then you know for a debt
collector a debt is a debt is a debt and
they don't care if like you didn't have
that surgery or you're not the right
Grace Elliott they're just going to go
after you
so starting next July the three main
credit reporting agencies are going to
be clearing uh medical debt off of
credit reports how important is this
well it's a it's kind of a first step
but it's not all medical debt right so
first what they're doing is they won't
put on medical debt that's under 500 but
if you walk into a U.S Hospital your
bill is going to be private right the
other thing they're going to do is
they're that they say that
if if you've paid it off it will be
removed but what we found is that a
hundred million Americans have medical
debt
um about a quarter of them have debt
that's more than five thousand dollars
so you know uh and and a quarter of the
people thought they would never be able
to pay off their debt in their lifetimes
yeah so it's going to be on their credit
so we need a lot more from Regulators on
this I know you've touched on it a
little bit but there's some people at
home that are walking past the TV and
they're stopping in their tracks because
they're in a similar situation like wait
a minute so what what can they do well
you know Grace Elliott the younger great
Sally did all the right things I think
you just have to be really really
persistent if that doesn't work I really
suggest calling your state Consumer
Protection Bureau because this is not a
medical issue it's a consumer issue
really and you know if all else fails
call Bill of the month well I was going
to say because it was through you we're
the final cops in this it was through
the efforts of Kaiser health news that
you all of a sudden the hospital
responded and I just wonder yeah not
everybody's going to know to do that
right and you can obviously investigate
everybody who comes to you but it was an
important point and you must be flooded
with people sending you there yeah we
have um thousands and thousands of bills
right now and it's you know a sign of
how dysfunctional our system is and how
unfair it is to people that we're the
solution we you know journalism
shouldn't be the solution to people
being in medical debt position thank you
for doing your part though Andrew Dr
Elizabeth Rosenthal thank you so much